Britain is a pretty good place to be if you're a disabled person in terms of sport.
We're the envy of the world in terms of our support structures,...
...our media coverage, the games that we're gonna be hosting.
We're using it as a platform to show the world what we can achieve.
And actually, you know, in the outside world away from sport,...
...it's still one of the best countries to be in.
Racing is amazing because it's speed, it's fear.
If you're on a road race, you can be going downhill at 50 miles an hour, 2 feet from the ground,...
...and your brakes don't really work.
It's exhaustion, it's elation, it's so many different things all wrapped up together.
And if you're competing on the track that can happen in 20 seconds,...
...it's the most amazing feeling.
But the outside world is so different from that.